[Music]
Hey give it back why you don't need any
more Jeff called me a disgusting fat pig
Jeff do not call your sister a fat pig
well she has turned it into a little
porker see that thinks you're a fat pig
I was teased a lot because of overweight
a lot of it was behind my back but then
a lot of it was also to my face which
made me feel terrible
hi wouldn't it be quicker if you just
smeared that on your thighs yeah - music
carbs so big you're blocking Sun wait
you got chocolate right there I know I'm
not the only one this sort of thing
happens all the time
[Music]
my name is Emmy and as the first
plus-size supermodel trust me I know
what it's like to be judged based on my
size but I'm also a mom and now one of
my life's greatest passion this is to be
a part of creating a world where
children can grow up happy successful
and fulfilled at any size I hope you're
willing to join me in that effort during
this program we're going to take a look
at what weight bias is how it shows up
at home and school who its victims and
sources are what its consequences are
and what we as parents and teachers can
do to improve the lives of children
we're surrounded by but first let's take
a look at how prevalent this problem is
obesity and children and adults has
doubled in the past 20 years
alarmingly its tripled in teens one in
five American children is overweight and
overweight children tend to become
overweight adults 30% of adults are
obese and we're right on track for this
trend to continue
there are many efforts underway to
address childhood obesity but we aren't
going to solve the nutritional and
lifestyle changes that plagued our
nation in the next 20 minutes but but we
are going to do this share with you some
new perspectives and tools that can help
you as parents and teachers stem the
tide of prejudice in our school system
and even at home so that children do not
remain vulnerable to the negative impact
of bias and stigma and so that we may
all begin to treat the many overweight
and obese people already in our lives
barely hey Ralph
what's not your lunchbox hair out peers
are frequent perpetrators of weight bias
with school being the most common
setting teasing can be in the form of
verbal and physical aggression as well
as social exclusion many students face
this torment daily it takes a toll on
their emotional and physical health and
reduces their quality of life one study
even found that the quality of life for
obese children is as low as children
with cancer
my friend was picked on by a teacher who
[Music]
he he called her like chubby and stuff
and I just thought that was very
uncalled for and a teacher shouldn't say
some anything like that
24% of overweight boys and 30% of
overweight girls experience prejudice in
middle school that bias doubles in high
school wear 58% of adolescent boys and
63% of adolescent girls are the victims
of peer teasing oh god here comes the
earthquake I've heard my friends talking
about a girl who's only slightly heavier
than me and like making fun of her and
it makes me wonder what they've said
behind my back
unfortunately attitudes towards weight
among children worsen over time we know
that weight bias begins as early as age
three in preschool and continues
throughout elementary school middle
school high school and even college so
overweight and obese children are
vulnerable targets of weight bias
throughout their educational careers
studies show that children as young as
three years old view overweight peers as
means stupid ugly unhappy lazy having
few friends and undesirable as playmates
this all just based on the size of their
bodies by three years old where does
this come from weight stigma comes from
a series of experiences that people have
just looking around them in the culture
they see how their parents discuss the
issue of weight they see how peers and
schools discuss it they see overweight
people ridiculed on television shows and
made fun of by comics and the like and
because of this they develop quite
negative attitudes that are very
difficult to change by the time their
children are in high school in college
they are experiencing multiple forms of
weight bias not just verbal comments or
physical aggression but also relational
victimization in the form of social
exclusion
a lot of people assume that overweight
people are dumb or lazy but most of the
time that's not the case
in fact I do well in school I get good
grades I'm part of the drama program I
exercise and I dance after school so
it's not it in most cases it's not true
people are afraid of what's different
from them and so by making them as less
of less of a person then I guess they
feel empowered behind their back they
might talk about oh look at that shirt
she was wearing her stomachs popping out
and everything I can't believe she'd
even think of wearing something like
that they'll just say like all these
like fat jokes about like like wide load
coming through and all this stuff and it
hurts me to see people getting treated
cuz I see how sad they are most of the
comments I get for them because some of
them are my friends they say they heard
comments like that before and you just
get used to it and that's a problem that
you're getting used to it that's
something he's not supposed to get used
to from nursery school through college
overweight students experience ostracism
discouragement and unfortunately even
violence for overweight students the
school experience is one of ongoing
prejudice unnoticed discrimination and
almost constant harassment overweight
children are more likely than normal
weight children to be victims of
bullying obese children age 12 to 16 are
more often the victims of repeated group
aggression or mobbing and sadly as a
defense mechanism
some of them resort to becoming bullies
themselves because they have nobody to
turn to for support or help I've seen a
couple kids that have been teased turn
into bullies because they basically are
trying to get back at everybody that has
teased them and even people that haven't
teased them and it's just they want to
put on this tough-guy reputation and it
just turns them into a bully the diet
and beauty industries bombard us day in
and
with the myth of the achievable perfect
body perpetuating the cultural premium
we place on thinness I think they might
think that fat people are nasty just
because they don't have the body of a
supermodel or something because they
supermodels don't even have that body
they retouched my computer so why does
everybody think that everyone has to
look like that clothes shopping is one
of my least favorite times of year like
going back to school and having to get a
new wardrobe and lots of times the
clothes don't fit I hate shopping let's
just go home you've gotta find something
you can't go naked fashion stupid why
can't I just wear something I already
have because nothing you have fits it it
makes me feel so like ugly weight stigma
blame and intolerance are not
constructive motivators for weight loss
they can actually have the opposite
effect our research shows that social
pressure and stigma do not motivate
weight loss and in fact have the
opposite effect for example we surveyed
over 2400 adults who were overweight and
obese and asked them about their
experiences of stigma and we found that
people reported coping with stigma by
eating more food and refusing to diet my
parents try to be supportive but most of
it just makes me feel worse they say
things to try and get me to lose weight
but it doesn't help at all and it kind
of makes me want to eat more victims of
weight bias are more susceptible to
loneliness depression anxiety low
self-esteem poor body image and suicidal
thoughts and behaviors look at this list
is this what we want for our children
certainly not but this is what weight
stigma gives them a quality of life that
no parent would wish for their child we
also know from research that children
who experience
by us are more likely to engage in
unhealthy eating behaviors like binge
eating and are more likely to avoid
physical activity both of which may only
reinforce additional weight gain and
obesity ramifications of stigma on
quality of life continue into adulthood
one study that I found particularly
alarming was that women who were
overweight as children or teenagers
still suffered significant wage
penalties even after they lost the
excess weight weight bias is very
socially acceptable in North American
society it's rarely challenged and it's
often ignored and as a result overweight
and obese individuals have very little
support when they confront weight bias
and as a result may internalize negative
stereotypes and blame themselves for the
negative attitude that they see the
stereotypes that characterize overweight
and obese people as dumb unsuccessful
stupid or lazy simply aren't true
think about the overweight people
already in your life family members
friends co-workers children maybe even
you have had a struggle with your weight
in the past we know that many people who
are overweight are intelligent
successful friendly and capable of
achieving the same goals as someone who
is not overweight people who are obese
are just like everybody else they live
they breathe they think they're just
like everyone else just because they're
a little heavier than other people
doesn't mean that they're less of a
person right
maybe they may have a couple extra
pounds but that's it underneath it all
they're all just like us expressing
negative attitudes towards obese people
has become one of the last accepted
forms of prejudice and could be as
hurtful and difficult to counter as
racial prejudice I see teachers like say
something in passing and they don't even
realize that it's offensive and they
just the teachers aren't any better than
the students sometimes I found a lot of
the teachers weren't as sympathetic as I
thought that you would imagine a teacher
should be
and the support really wasn't there for
some of his his years and it really hurt
him I'd hurt him a lot you just feel low
a low and you just don't know what to do
so you make you try to you try to
comfort yourself with food or games
inside all day or stuff like that
overweight youth are not only teased at
school but peer harassment can come in
the form of verbal teasing physical
bullying or social rejection from family
members to
you're a disgusting fat pig now she is
turned into a little porker nothing you
have fits what if your child is the
victim of weight bias here are some
suggestions of ways to talk to your
child about these issues and find ways
to intervene offer support and help your
child cope hey there how was your day
great just alright yeah I think one of
the most important things that needs to
happen between a parent and a child is
open communication and that's really the
groundwork that needs to be you know set
from the beginning so you want to have a
relationship with your child where they
feel like they can come and talk to you
about a range of things so things that
are going well in their lives and then
things that aren't going so well and one
way to facilitate that is for the parent
to try to retain somewhat of a neutral
stance when their child starts telling
them about a difficult situation
these boys we called me fat I don't
really know who they are
Oh sweetie I'm sorry I'm sorry it
happened when did that happen to you at
lunch if your child has had their
self-esteem damaged through a situation
where someone has discriminated against
them because of their weight or bullied
them because of their weight I think
parents need to be very direct and tell
them that they that they did not deserve
to be treated this way and also to
remind them of all the strengths they
have as a person so how did that make
you feel it really hurt I felt like no
one was there for me and nobody had my
back
but you know I have your back always
right and
you know mrs. Johnson your English
teacher I think she's somebody that you
could go to and turn to she loves you
you know that she's she said such lovely
things about you at the open house okay
I think that's someone you can trust and
turn to all right sweetie okay
well fortunately schools have developed
policies and procedures to deal with
bullying in recent years they're much
more aware of these problems so it makes
sense for the parent to work with their
child on a plan to go to the school talk
with a guidance counselor a principal
may be a trusted teacher and really
think about the best way that the child
should handle themselves in school to
avoid future situations
so what can we do at home or in the
classroom as parents and teachers
there's a lot we can do the first step
to changing any stereotype or
eradicating prejudice is to be aware
start paying attention to your own
attitudes about wait educate yourself
about the causes of obesity so that you
will be informed so that you can help
your children and students understand
the various causes of obesity the causes
of obesity are very complex it is a
combination of genetic factors
environmental factors psychological
factors and it's important to recognize
that so that when we look at someone and
we see whatever their body weight is we
don't make assumptions about their
behaviors based on that information
there's genetics involved it's not just
like eating too much because I eat
better than anything a lot of the people
that I know and I exercise more it's
just the way I am
another thing that people can do parents
and teachers in particular to change the
environment of our children is what we
call avoid fat talk and fat talk kind of
goes like this
it's when one person says oh I feel so
fat today and then the other person says
oh no you're not fat I'm fat look at my
thighs and then the other person says oh
no your thighs look great I'm the one
who's really fat this is a problem
because when people talk this way they
are communicating to children
number one that
your body size is a very important thing
and number two that how you feel on any
given day is going to be related to
whether or not you're feeling fat that
day be alert to both overt and subtle
forms of pure harassment that occur in
the classroom or on the playground and
intervene when you see weight based
teasing encourage your students to
intervene and stand up for their peers
hi wouldn't it be quicker if you just
smeared that on your thighs yeah can you
say carbs which problem
what are you the pig's keeper my brother
saw people making fun of me at school
one day and he came and he stood up for
me and it makes me feel good to know
that somebody accepts me for who I am
[Music]
one problem right now is that it's very
rare for children to see role models who
are not very thin or do not have an
ideal body type so one thing that
parents and teachers can do is they can
really seek out those sorts of
individuals and hold them up as role
models for children so they can look in
the media they can look into sports or
other to other celebrities and find
people who can serve as role models and
really represent very diverse body types
be sensitive to situations of potential
embarrassment for overweight students I
actually spoke with a parent ones who
told me about her daughter who was in
kindergarten that when she arrived for
school the teacher had set up this
special table and chair in a completely
separate area of the classroom off away
from the other children
because the teacher felt that the child
would not fit into the regular desks
this is really an example of how it is
communicated to the child you don't fit
in here you don't belong here
treat weight tolerance with the same
significance as you would racial or
religious tolerance
try to promote awareness of weight bias
be a role model by enforcing a zero
tolerance policy of weight based easing
in your classroom oh god here comes the
earthquake
[Applause]
[Applause]
at the Rudd Center we work hard to
eliminate the problem of weight bias we
believe that there's a strong social
injustice occurring here that hundreds
of millions of people around the world
are deeply affected by this and it just
doesn't need to occur race bias doesn't
need to occur gender bias doesn't need
to occur and whey bias doesn't need to
occur we all want the same things for
our kids don't we happy healthy
childhoods thank you so much for joining
us today and in the future as we strive
to improve the quality of life for a
kids through not just physical activity
in nutritious eating but by creating a
world where we all can be successful and
fulfilled at any weight for more
information please visit the Rudd Center
for Food Policy and obesity at Yale red
cent org
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]